[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
what is good everyone
it's Thursday
you know what time it is I got my boy
producer Ryan with me we do not have
Greg ivory with us we miss him dude you
guys are you guys are playing musical
chairs as of late last week it was just
me and him now it's just me and you are
you guys beating I don't know no no
never any beef with my man G money he's
got other obligations obviously the most
famous man in Bedding I would say but
listen it's the last one of these we are
at the end of the regular season in the
NBA so we got to cook up our final
FanDuel parlay for a slate that's gonna
be pretty interesting Ryan we were
talking about it off air interesting is
a word might not have a lot of star
power tonight so how you feeling about
the sleigh I feel pretty good I feel
even better because B Thompson who is
the ultimate Vibes guy uh in this chat
uh jumped in 35 minutes ago and said we
getting a freaking dub tonight let's go
jumped in 30 minutes I don't even know
if I was in this room 35 minutes ago he
beat me to it and said we're getting a
dub tonight so I you know
no better feeling than that no those are
Immaculate Vibes I'm about to hop in the
chat as well just so I can see all the
vibey people we got in here B Thompson
like you said Mike we're getting this
dub absolutely 100 so drop your locks
for tonight we have two games on TNT
Heat versus Sixers nuggets versus Suns
and like we said at the top
might have some people sitting out so
maybe avoid some of those big names I
don't think taking Joyland beat over 30
and a half points is a smart play how
about you Ryan I think that's a I think
that's a phenomenal place to start
because uh again I'm not trying to make
this Ryan's parlay you know you know me
I'm never trying to make this Ryan's
parlay never one time uh but I think we
are in a beautiful spot to take a minus
110 that I think should probably be
minus 500 in Joel and beat under 30 and
a half points uh I just in no way shape
or form see the Philadelphia 76ers
playing him long enough tonight for that
to happen I just don't I don't see it
they they have nothing to play for
yeah I agree they have nothing to play
for uh we'll touch on this a little
later as well but it sounds it seems
like to me Joelle embiid's got the MVP
wrapped up after having 52 points
against your Boston Celtics the other
night so all right well I I had to sneak
it in yeah thanks thank you for that um
but we've talked a lot All Season about
potentially doing an unders parlay what
better time than the last slate of the
year I don't know could be fun I I agree
with you I think this is honestly I do
think this is a good place to start I'm
interested to see the rest of the chats
Vibes we got uh our guide my guy my guy
Darian in here uh bk37
um well Darian jumped in here and said I
don't even want another record at this
point neither do I there's a reason I
don't we don't come on here and say
neither me or you don't say the record
anymore because it's there's no
points we don't care dude this is this
is about to the end of the regular
season the only thing that matters is
moving forward is winning when it counts
uh but tonight I want to know for the
day that's all we need we just have to
go 1-0 for the day but no I am I am with
you with the with the Joe uh Joel embed
stuff I think also too you brought up a
good point with the MVP it's like
he yes he is playing tonight but I also
think a part of this is just like
getting him out on the floor so people
who are voting for embiid for MVP can be
like okay like it's like oh okay he
played another game you know what I mean
it's not like it's how it affected his
MVP ads when he went up head to head
against jokic and then didn't play and
it knocked him down a peg I think this
is just like get him out on the floor
play him 15 to 20 minutes and then say
okay bye go take a shower and go home so
I'm in on this I'm in on this
yeah I I'm in on it as well
um I want to know what the chat thinks
about potentially going under on MB
points listen if you think about it he
has been a monster and he scored over 30
he's been averaging over 30 but in a
game that you don't need and you know
you need to show face so the voters
don't knock your odds down a peg I don't
think there's any way he plays the
second half he may not even play after
the first quarter so yeah I'm good with
this we also see B Thompson in the chat
saying Harden Aid assists lock
I don't even know if I like that man no
because it's like again like are they
also I thought earlier when I checked he
he was at 10 and a half for he's at nine
and a half now
it's going down yeah these again
are they gonna play
this is the so so my thought and like I
want to know the chat's opinion
I I think these games where it can be
like a rest situation like
I see Ritter in the chat let's go all
unders tonight I'm super aligned with
that that sounds like the way to go and
if we get you know James Harden throws
nine assisted I don't even know who's on
there but George nyang like then we tip
our hats and we move right let's go all
honors and like we're getting this one
at plus money as well like I don't know
I I think
did we finally figure it out though like
I think we might have figured this one
out
yeah this feels this feels sharp to me
yeah I don't say it feels great I mean
like I I can't I can't live I don't I
don't want to live in a world where like
we're betting on people who are not
gonna like we're gonna need Joel embiid
and uh James Harden to do all their work
in eight minutes like no way I'm not
yeah right also like bam out of Bio does
exist so like on the Joel embiid front
like you know I I don't know like he
could play he could play 15 minutes do I
necessarily think it's gonna be easy for
him to score 31 points uh the answer for
me is gonna be no there uh Glizzy said
that the Celtics didn't need to play
last night the Celtics didn't need to
win last night but they did I mean
that's a fair point but also like the
guys on the Celtics I mean Jalen Brown
had 25 points but everyone else like
Mike muscala had 17 like hey I don't
know like again it's a situation where
like You'll Play Your stars but you're
not playing them enough to like go
nuclear 100 100 I see bagel and locks in
the chat niang two plus threes is so
smacky this is something that I've
played kind of often this year I the
only reason why he's the name that
popped in my head is because he's like
the only off-ball player that I ever
been on for the Sixers so I kind of like
that b Thompson saying let's do unders
for the Sixers game only
okay did the Nuggets did the did the
Nuggets wrap up the one seed I think
they did yeah they did I imagine they're
gonna they're gonna be sitting some
people as well
um I have a stat I'm coming with a scoop
James Harden has gone over his points
total 20 and a half only twice in his
last 10 games that's just some
information to share but uh it is what
it is what is oh yeah
I mean
this one's scary though yeah this one's
scary though because if he ends up being
the one person the one star that plays
the whole game he'll easily score 21
points so maybe we leave that one alone
I
also beat some good points being dropped
in the chat here from freesh who was
told by I think bk37 that that doesn't
sound like that doesn't sound like fresh
to you
[Music]
there's no extra e
yeah okay that's fair also hold on I
want to address this bk37 came in here
and said Dante divincenzo points bk37
I don't know how often you watch this
show I know you're you're a br betting
Legend I know that you're a community
Legend but I don't know how often you
watch this show Dante's even shenzo next
to Kyrie Irving for me is my enemy wait
we don't like him on this show that's a
that's a fat no I may take his I don't
even know if the I don't even know if
the Warriors play today oh yeah wait
what what are we doing that's I I
actually think okay wait we gotta we
gotta scoop highest odds says do not do
embed under if he hits 30 plus he locks
up the scoring title basically
does that matter I wonder I wonder if
that matters to him he's already won the
MVP
how many points did he can't see he
needs at least 30.
do you want to just like bump up oh God
I hate this man I you know I was really
hoping to just take straight unders and
then move on but like it's not a bad
point if we just go to like 30
four and a half
and 10 minus 270. I feel very good about
that I feel good about the 30 and a half
but yeah I'm so down all right um we
also have
where did I see this uh dude I'm rich
man
awesome name hard and under assist so I
think we could probably lock that into
um his assist if we want to go all I
would say he's not gonna get 10 if we
want it to be that way
um because I think you said it dropped
down to nine and a half
uh yeah it dropped out of nine and a
half
um
Ben Harkey saying scoring title matters
to him drizz13 with some info Joker's
out tonight good to know glad we know
that now
the nuggets are not very much in good
form lately but I think their coach very
explicitly said we're just focused on
playoffs so
okay uh somebody had dropped uh oh it
was uh fresh who I called Fresh
we never got over that
um but said that the heat needs to win
tonight to stay out of the play-in and
I'm gonna fact check him there uh yeah I
mean yeah that's a real thing uh so okay
um
does heat money line appeal to you at
all or the points
I have I have some interest in the
points
um I also think it might be a good
opportunity to look at Jimmy's points
total over I know you used to play with
the Sixers
um but yeah I mean every team is going
to want to avoid that playing game if
they can I know they're right there on
the bubble so maybe that is a good play
um
yeah I could I could go I could see like
Jimmy Butler over 20 points being
something that's interesting as a leg
here uh KB 225 saying Jimmy B 20 points
or five assists so
um I
I yeah
I like
I like Jimmy I feel like and I don't
know why I like the heat more so I'm I'm
down to okay the West Side McFly every
now and I gotta look over at the chat
and something just kind of like throws
me off my my tracks all the free throws
got you where
can I even bet that I don't think I can
no I can't I mean no no
stat leaders baby
B Thompson saying hero two threes he's
as he's sure that his over under is at
two and a half
okay
let's let's check it out also niang is
not up on the board so just to Circle
back to the niang two plus threes
uh two and a half
two threes
I I could be I could be down with that
are you saying two plus are you saying
over two and a half two plus
let's see what that does for us
okay we're at 237 now here's the
crossroads right yep the suns are really
good with Kevin Durant in the lineup and
I think they're definitely still playing
for seating positioning whatever you
want to call it uh do we skip over to
that game and see what's going on with
the old Phoenix Suns because
gotta say man I'm glad I got a ticket on
him uh they're 12 point favorites
tonight we gotta avoid a blowout but I
think that there's ways that we can do
that with some of these player props are
you glad you have a ticket on them with
the potential of them playing The
Warriors in the first round
it's a little scary but that's why I
think they need to win as many games as
they can to get out of their way man
that's because the Warriors are getting
healthy that's the scary part the
Warriors are getting healthy but also if
you are able to get the Suns if you're
somebody who has a ticket on the Suns to
to win it all and they get the four seed
I think you're in a good position
because the Warriors and I don't have
Greg to interrupt me here so this is
pretty this is pretty nice the the
Warriors cannot win on the road they
they can't that's true they will not
actually uh they refuse to so I think
having home home court advantage uh will
be huge but all right so they're 12
point their 12 point favorites tonight
uh what do you like
uh I'm seeing B Thompson saying KD 20
plus points uh CP3 7.5 over seven and a
half assists Ritter also likes KD 20
points so not sure what his line is set
at 24 and a half is that 24.
probably going to be odds probably won't
be great but
I mean it gets us close to where we
usually like to be
okay
another leg Yeah right we got another
leg to go KD is obviously KD I think he
can get 20 in his sleep
um
yeah let's see okay so now we need one
leg left
we we definitely abandoned the O of the
unders you saw that coming soon
that's by the way facts love is roasting
Ritter uh so I'm gonna let Ritter take
the heat for that because this guy
pointed out the fresh thing in the chat
as well
um
but okay I I like yeah right elbe with
KD for uh five first quarter points I
feel like elbe doesn't get enough credit
for me for the amount of times this guy
comes in and drops the weirdest place
I'm not gonna say good or bad I'll just
say they're unique
and that's and that's elbe's gig I I
don't know I don't know much else about
it but
um all right we need one more leg I
think we're I think we're in a good spot
um we're sure that the suns are gonna
take care of business they need this
game a lot more than the Nuggets do the
Nuggets have locked up the first seed
um
Fred albinos saying Sons Plus or Sun's
win margin I got KB 225 saying Booker
two threes
I'm I like Booker threes better than I
like betting on a team to win by 12 as
the last leg but yeah I don't know what
do you think Ryan
I I also I also agree let's let's go
over this real quick just so we all know
where we're at here
um right now we have James Harden under
nine and a half assists Joe Ellen beat
under 34.5 points Tyler hero two plus
made threes and then uh Kevin Durant 20
plus points
um
I kind of like the Nuggets to cover 12
points
um only because I a lot a lot of these
teams have been covering these Mammoth
spreads and the nuggets for a reason
it's not all just jokic
um so the only reason why I would push
back on that is because it's in Phoenix
um yeah I feel like Denver's so good at
home and like if they were playing in
front of the home crowd I'd probably be
on board because the trend has been
double-digit spreads are covering like
crazy over the last two weeks so I don't
think it's a bad take I'm just scared to
do that on an opposing team's court and
you know you don't have anything to put
I mean like we could this could be the
Christian Braun Show for like 32 minutes
yeah you're right you're right
um okay darian85 saying eight in
rebounds I know his number's usually
High over 10 and a half is plus 106.
what if we went to like eight maybe see
what that does read my mind if that guy
can't get eight boards
then we got big problems okay
I kind of like this at plus 447. what do
you think Ryan eight boards with no
yokich I like it I like it this is the
only this is the only thing I'll say and
I was gonna bring it up earlier now it's
gonna seem like I'm back on my [__]
but James Harden
I would like to possibly bump up the
assist a little bit just to give us some
nice cushion
okay
all right okay uh you know I'm certainly
cool with that listen I just want to see
this one go through the hoop not because
what our record is because the record
doesn't matter no no I don't even do we
even have a record we don't have a
record I heard somebody put in here that
the record's been expunged we appreciate
that judge
um what we need to do though Ryan is see
one go through the hoop and take us into
the playoffs with a dub so we got to
move that we got to move that number up
I'm cool with that all right I I those
are things I love to hear yeah we the
the worst thing that they could let us
do bowling right before the playoffs is
let us get hot that's the worst let us
get hot yeah do not do that that's a bad
idea that would be the worst for the
world because you know what's gonna
happen Ryan we're gonna go to the next
team meeting on Tuesday and say
everybody else has kicked off any
playoff shows it's just me and you and
then we get to go to all the games so if
you let us get hot it's watch out we're
gonna be me and you are gonna be playing
ISO ball that's just what it is it's
gonna be like that that Shaq and Kobe uh
mixtape that's that's what's gonna be us
uh I see uh hark7 is saying hero threes
is a trap okay I I like the take also
how in the world did the juice on this
where did it all go
this is yes yeah oh my goodness okay
we're in trouble that's that we have 11
minutes to try and figure this out but
this is uh this is not a place I like to
be I think we go back to the original
stick with our guns and
yeah I mean I don't think they're gonna
I don't think they're gonna play that
much honestly
what I want I want the Chapstick I want
the chatstick I do all right chat you
see the you see the parlay on the screen
we got embiid under 34 and a half hard
and under nine and a half assists hero
two plus made threes Durant 20 points
eight and eight rebounds thumbs up if
you're riding thumbs down if you think
we should change it up I really like it
Ryan I'm not gonna lie to you I think
that this is a good bet truthfully
oh wait is this right oh you're you're
tinkering because I see the under 11 and
a half assist right there yeah I'm not
I'm also not saying that
we have this
saying right now we're at plus 269 and
if we want to try and mix something it
just to me the fact that I bumped it up
two assists is crazy to me that the that
these odds jumped the way that they did
I I
someone's saying elbe sang embiid under
32 and a half
oh yeah and he needed 30 for is it a
situation where he gets 30 any any
leaves
yeah
so then there's not a situation if we're
saying if like right he he could do that
situation where we can get cooked though
because like if say he had 29 and he
hits a three to clinch that that's 32.
then we're good okay all right maybe we
just cracked the code
might have done it
uh
okay under 32 and a half okay I mean I'm
not gonna say we're back because we're
not but we're close
eight and nine four no I I like eight
and that eight boards that's this is my
problem
me too what about Harden's original line
ten and a half
ten and a half I
I feel great about 11 and I feel good
about 10. so as long as I as long as
we're still feeling good
reset what happened what I feel like we
had it
we did
highest odds highest odds is going nuts
in the chat saying we don't know the
situation
do not go under on and beat anymore he
doesn't clinch tonight
I I don't I don't get it he all right
are you telling us the wrong information
you're the one that told us that he's
gonna score it so we're trying to go
under a higher number I'm not a yeah I'm
not a blame the chat guy but the only
reason I ever thought this to begin with
is because uh uh it was dropped in the
chat again not the chat's fault but if
we were to point a finger at somebody
that might be where it lands
he's saying a bee can't clinch the more
he scores the further away 30 to 35
makes Luca need around 95 over the next
two games to beat him so it kind of
sounds like it doesn't matter then
okay
all right
I yeah oh okay how about this okay or
let's I feel like we can figure this out
in an instant I because people are rush
out of time I know people in the chat
are freaking about freaking out about
Tyler hero I think we can all agree on
this I think the Miami Heat are going to
have to play a really good game tonight
they're two and a half Point underdogs
we don't need to take the money line I
think if we just because Tyler hero is a
minus 470 like we're forgetting about
that I think if we swipe that out
because people are freaking out that he
can't hit two threes I think they can
cover I really do that's minus one and
then we can do everything else the way
that we did before
perfect
this the chat man
I said this last time I understand
sometimes you just need to drink I
understand that it's like really hard to
like explain what you're trying to do in
like nine in like five six chats yeah
but I just got so lost for a second I
see Mike Ritter in the comments like my
mind is in a pretzel yes that's exactly
how I feel oh my goodness and we're just
like just under it
uh
I what if we did over 20 and a half
points for Durant so like 21 plus
essentially no no no no no let's leave
it at 20. and guess what
we're adding another leg put the booker
threes in there or B Thompson saying do
not we want to see it go through we want
to see it go through
I feel like there there's got to be one
what if we did or do you feel good about
Harden 10 and a half assists
yeah okay I do all right
drop your pretzels in the chat to
reflect the way my mind feels right now
yeah actually
yep all right let's let's make that
quick switch to 10 and let's lock ten
and a half unless and we're okay we're
24. yes so all right read them read them
the parlay because we're locked in last
question do we want to buy the hook on
the heat
it's gonna it's gonna take us under it
is do you yeah try it all right I think
it's gonna take us under real quick
uh
I I don't want to push I'm sorry
I do like the fact that we could
let's go nope we got it we bought the
hook we're back all right we're in add
that let's do it add that point five in
there okay let's do this so this is the
this is the parlay Joel embiid under 35
and a half points James Harden under 10
and a half assists the Miami Heat plus
two and a half
bought the hook go buy the hook Kevin
Durant didn't move it no it didn't move
we're at the same we're at the same spot
pretty much uh Kevin Durant 20 plus
points and DeAndre in eight plus
rebounds five legs plus 424
go tell us on FanDuel
I I'm not gonna say it because I've been
saying it for the past few weeks but all
yes go ahead yeah do it screenshot it
screenshot it there we go screenshot it
don't ask me in three minutes what's the
parlay don't do that highest odds oh oh
you pushed it to 35 and a half epic move
We Are Men of the people today yes as we
are every week but we're learning we're
learning all right go tail us on FanDuel
and we will be meeting you at the
cashier all right quickly Ryan couple
quick hitters end of the regular season
don't need to spend a lot of time on
this because we've talked about it a lot
the MVP race
it started heavy joke uh Nicoli jokic
and now Joe Ellen beat is minus one
thousand to win his first MVP it's over
right uh it's it's cooked yeah it's done
it's tough for me too because like I
really enjoyed the whole second place
thing that was going on with you know
Philly and him never being able to win
one but it's done yeah you feel the same
we're worried about the playoffs it's
all over next
let's talk like in
we got the Mavericks on the line we got
the Lakers on the line
the Clippers last night they didn't look
very good Lebron called their scheduling
here which one do you see I mean
but which one of these teams you think
has the best chance to make a run at the
title yeah and it was time it's tough
for the Lakers and LeBron because I know
that they had to travel so far for their
Road game yesterday against the Los
Angeles Clippers so it's real this is
real tough for the Lakers
um
here's the thing I
these odds are only to to make the
play-in tournament uh I I I would
I would probably say the Thunder or
probably the best value here only
because I really really think the Mavs
are going to miss it
um and if there was a missed Market here
I would have been all over the maps to
miss it but I I think I I Never Love A
minus 210 if you like something else on
the Slate toss it in with the Thunder to
make it but like I think that's probably
where I lean here what about you
so if we're asking who I think is gonna
make a run
um it's hard to say that the Lakers are
going to be bad in the postseason
whether they make the plan or actually
make the playoffs but the interesting
team is the Mavericks in my opinion uh
they're on the outside looking in right
now they don't really control their own
destiny they're going to play against
the Bulls who are horrific tomorrow I
believe Levine and DeRozan will not be
playing so that's an auto win for the
Mavericks when you got two guys like
Luca and Kyrie on the same team in a
playoff series where the game gets
called a little differently
If You're Gonna Roll the Dice on
anything here I think it's probably the
Mavs
yeah I think that's
I don't know man yeah I'll say that's
probably a good call but I'll say I'm
not going to bet it because I don't bet
on Kyrie Irving that's just not what I
do
yeah that's very on brand for you so I
won't I won't push you on it but last
lastly we have one playoff series that's
locked in and that is the Knicks and the
Cavs and we're looking at the odds right
now
I know you're not a Knicks guy I know
you're very much not a Knicks guy very
much
I want to know your take on this as on
our way out because this is interesting
I think the Knicks have a halfway decent
chance in the series and at the price
they've kind of
it's hard to bet the cabs at this price
I think once we get and I it's not up at
the current moment but once we get a
playoff series spread
I think taking the Knicks say I'm gonna
guess it's gonna come out at plus one
and a half I would say take the Knicks
there I don't know if I don't think they
I think the Knicks are frauds genuinely
but I think Jalen Brunson is him and
we'll step up to the plate
um and Julius randle's been there before
I know not everyone loves Julius Randle
I don't love Julius Randle RJ Barrett uh
is very like the Knicks have guys
Emmanuel quickly is probably Sixth Man
of the Year they have guys
um so I I think take the serious spread
I don't think they win it but I think
they make it competitive
so I'm also very much not a next guy my
grandma would be very upset with me if
she listened to me talk anything nicely
about the Knicks so I'm not really going
to I'm gonna just say this
if you don't have confidence in the Cavs
I would bet the Knicks and then just bet
the Cavs and head your way out of it
it's not fun it's not sexy but
it all depends on how healthy Julius
Randle is and we're not sure of that so
like like you said taking the serious
price at minus 200 is no fun get
yourself some value if you have to bet
this gun to your head take the Knicks
otherwise probably just leave it alone
because you don't want to be in a
position where everyone's roasting the
Knicks on Twitter and you're the one
with a sad losing ticket so it's not
gonna be me it sounds like it's
certainly not going to be producer Ryan
no no I think that's probably how it
should be yeah I I will say this I'm
looking at the the total games here I
like six six games I know I just said
take the Knicks plus one and a half so
you know hand up might be a fraud there
but I like I like six games
yeah I mean I do think they do think
there's something about playing at
Madison Square Garden uh they didn't
really show it last year but I think
this team is better obviously Jalen
brookson puts them over the top so could
be a deep series I don't love a lot of
things about the Cavs I think they can
be pretty sad and sometimes so that's
not a bad bet it's definitely not going
to be a sweep so six games gets you good
value but
we got to get out of here man we're up
against the clock this is really fun
doing this just you and I we're just
channeling The Vibes I thought we went
through the chat pretty nicely so if you
want to run through the parlay quickly
one more time I don't know if you have
it nearby if you don't Greg's not here
and you're still having me do this
nonsense this is tough
It's Joel embiid under 35 and a half
points James Harden under 10 and a half
assists the Miami Heat plus two and a
half Kevin Durant to score 20 plus
points and DeAndre in eight plus
rebounds it's now plus 415 on FanDuel go
tell us there uh before that price
continues to drop but yeah shout out to
everyone in the chat who's been with us
all regular season and who continue to
come and and uh drop their takes and and
Vibe with us it's been uh it's been a
hell of a regular season and I'm excited
to cash in the playoffs
yes sir and just like you said in the
playoffs we have more shows on the way
we will keep you posted and program app
social everywhere thanks for riding with
us and I'll see you guys at the bank
tonight baby peace
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]